there's a phenomenon that I've noticed
and also been more and more taking note
of in recent years that I don't quite
have a name for the closest thing that
I've settled on to it in you know
talking about it in ama sessions and
occasional other places is that some
classic and contemporary philosophical
texts have what I would call a kind of
Aura to them they become you could say
within the intellectual sphere a kind of
commodity right something that is
reference something that is sampled
something that is traded upon invoked
but oftentimes not actually read or for
those who do the reading sometimes not
adequately understood I'll give you a
prime example of a text that I think has
this kind of stature and I do want to
say ahead of time all of these texts I
think are worth reading and they're um
you know not to be just discarded as
being jargon or a bunch of you know
poorly formed strung together ideas or
anything like that all of them are worth
reading but I think a lot of people
don't actually read the text and get a
lot more out of glosses on them so
here's a prime example of a text like
that hegel's phenomenology of spirit
right
this is the Miller translation there
have been three new recent translations
in English that have come out in the
last several years and there's earlier
translations as well
um this is a great book right it's not
the key to everything and maybe that's
another thing that we can say about
these texts with auras is that so many
people take them as if they're like this
is the definitive work that you must
read or you're not understanding
philosophy you're not doing philosophy
in a meaningful way I mean
before Hegel people were clearly doing
philosophy uh maybe not in exactly the
same way that Hegel was but it's not as
if there wasn't great value in the
discipline before that and you don't
have to be a hegelian or even a constant
reader of hegel's phenomenology of
Spirit in order to do many things in
philosophy quite well and interestingly
and you know rigorously this is one
possible way to go this is only one of
hegel's books too I mean this was not a
particularly important book in the 19th
century by comparison to the 20th and
the 21st century where this one became
like the book to to go to certainly at
least in the English-speaking world for
Hegel fanciers right and so this is this
is a great example of a text people
think that oh there's so much in here
but many people only read little
sections of it and they find that
difficult like the Master Slave
dialectic right
um The Master Slave dialectic by the way
is just a tiny tiny I'm actually going
to include not well we'll just include
lordship and bondage in here right and
so that's this amount of this entire
text
so if you're not reading the rest of it
and you're bringing up hegel's Master
Slave dialectic all the time you got to
ask well what are you doing you know or
if you bring up the unhappy
Consciousness or if you bring up his
discussion of Antigone or if you bring
up and we could go on and on and on and
on right so this is a prime example of a
text with that kind of Aura I would say
the majority of people that I see on
social media bringing up Hegel focus on
this text as if it's like the go-to
place for philosophy and very often
betray that they don't know much about
it what would be some other similar
texts well here's another prime example
that I think the German idealists
themselves sometimes appeal to Benedict
Spinoza's ethics right very interesting
text worth reading a lot of people get
out of my case because I I haven't done
videos about it but I haven't done
videos on many many philosophers but
this is the most requested one and you
know you think to yourself well what is
so attractive about this incredibly
convoluted
um arranged in a really weird
presentation style this Moray
geometrical which essentially
puts out a a metaphysics that is hard to
buy into and
um you know
views on the human emotions that I
certainly myself don't don't accept what
is so attractive about this almost like
you know a black hole sucking everything
else into it well you know I think this
is a text that just like the
phenomenology has a stellar reputation
and a lot of people are paying more
attention to the reputation than what's
actually contained in the text let alone
having a fairly comp comprehensive
understanding of what the overall
philosophy there is and here's another
prime example you know
this is often const critique of pure
reason the first critique viewed as like
well if you haven't read that then you
haven't actually studied philosophy Kant
is such an important transition figure
philosophy can't be the same again after
Kant and you know if you know your
history of philosophy you can be like
well sure it can I mean he's very
important but so many other people are
very important throughout history and
yeah there's some really cool stuff
going on in this that leads to some you
know interesting discussions and
adaptations and interpretations and
controversies and all that and you know
there's a sort of comprehensive picture
of the world us as human beings our
faculties how we know things give it in
here I mean it's a great book right it's
well worth reading but it's not the
be-all and end-all of philosophy any
more than Spinoza's ethics or hegel's
phenomenology are it's not even the be
all and end-all of kant's works I mean
given the chance to to reread the
critique of pure reason or to reread
either of the other two critiques I'm
always choosing the other critiques
because I find them more interesting
myself but this is the one that
everybody hears about and they're like
oh yes I definitely have to make time to
read this I've had quite a few tutorials
students who will you know get in touch
with me and they're like I want to do
tutorials with you I want to read this
book and I'll be like are you sure
that's the one the single thing that you
really want to concentrate on the most
well I've heard it's so important well
how do you know that it's so important
until you actually get into it and you
read it and you see whether it is so or
Not Another Prime Contender you know as
we're moving forward from Hegel
Karl Marx right I mean how many people
who call themselves
marxists and and people who call
themselves marxists are often very very
committed aren't they they uh think that
that you know this is really Central to
um how we should understand everything
like this is the book it's not uh the
critique of pure reason it's not hegel's
phenomenology it's this instead how many
of them have actually read their way
through this let alone assimilated it
and understand it understood it
probably not that many right
um it assumes it you know you could say
that all of these books assume the kind
of importance that many people Accord to
religious texts like the Bible which
itself is a composite of all these
different Works written at different
times often you know kind of
Illuminating but at Cross purposes with
each other people act as if the book
itself is somehow you know going to
change your life and you you need to
adapt yourself to it it's it's
authoritative in an interesting way and
we can talk about other things from the
20th century I've just got a few here
that I think are not given that sort of
status anymore but have been treated at
one point or another is if they're like
absolutely centrally important and
invoked but often not talked about great
example Heidegger's being in time right
I mean the most interesting thing for me
in this is the four Aqua primordials
um if you don't know what that is well
you know maybe you have read being in
time but you didn't pay close enough
attention to that being towards death is
a cool idea but you know that's just one
possible uh comportment right that that
comes out of that there's all sorts of
other things in here that get brought up
occasionally you know let's talk about
this let's talk about that you know the
the dasman right that's sort of like the
catchphrase of
um you know talking about the Master
Slave dialectic or pick whatever else
that you you want so I mean a lot of
people made a big deal out of being in
time in the past maybe less so nowadays
um two others that were viewed as like
oh these are the must see must read must
go to books wittgenstein's philosophical
investigations this one's particularly
thick because it's got the German on one
side and the English on the other which
is very nice to be able to consult but I
mean when you read the philosophical
investigations yes there's this idea of
language game which is cool connected to
form of life and there's all these
interesting examples and and you know
questions that he brings up and family
definitions in place of family
resemblance definitions and stuff like
that but
it's a lot of vickenstein just kind of
circling around
interesting questions that he's
definitely not the first person to raise
right but people treated this as if like
this is the book that you must pass
through right
for existentialism if it wasn't
Heidegger it was this one being and
nothingness right this even made its way
into movies as sort of like a stand-in
for what a true intellectual would be
reading if you've ever seen the movie
Roxanne with
um Steve Martin and I forget who else
was in it there's this uh
um this intellectually oriented firemen
who this other guy who's kind of a
hunkish you know kind of character he's
supposed to be like you know very
attractive he goes in and he buys this
book at the bookstore for the other guy
and then the main female lead thinks oh
he's really really smart why because
this was a stand-in for being smart for
considering things and everybody knows
like the waiter who's too much of a
waiter and you know looking at the P the
peephole the keyhole right people know
those sorts of examples but that's just
tiny little bit of what's actually going
on in this very interesting book all of
these are what we call books with I call
it books with aura people used them or
use them as sort of stand-ins for what
it means to have a comprehensive world
view and to be an intellectual and you
know to look at things philosophically I
have a few other ones as well that I I
want to bring up one of which is
probably no longer it doesn't have the
aura that it used to have but you know
back when I was in graduate school
this was considered hot stuff you know
on grammatology I I mean I remember
reading my way through it in uh the
French uh original that my my mom had
bought me and then you know talking with
other people who were using this uh uh
you know version as well and it's cool
you know it's great
but it's you know sort of like hegel's
phenomenology or Spinoza's ethics or the
first critique of you know Emmanuel Kant
it's great but it's not the single book
that we should all look to and talk
about this one kind of has fallen out of
prominence but there's another book from
you know the same era that people are
still constantly
referencing and talking about and again
not knocking these books they're worth
reading
but do a lot of people who read
anti-edipus and talk about it really
fully understand it or is it more like
I'm on team to lose in Qatari and I'm
going to talk a lot about the body
without organs and you know bring up
schizoanalysis and you know all that
sort of stuff that could be another way
of talking about these books with aura
they the people who treat them that way
they treat it as if these are emblems
mascots
uniforms for a team that they are on and
I'll bring up another one that has a
similar sort of thing another book that
a lot of people talk about I don't think
that many people actually do in fact
read because it's a tough read
Lawrence Becker is a new stoicism very
important for you know this paying
attention to stoic philosophy in the
21st century I mean it it was a slow
burn for it right because when it first
come out in 1998 you know a little bit
before the turn of the century and it's
a it's a great book but it is difficult
it is tough and that's before you get to
the um you know the appendix with the
calculus for normative logic stuff so I
would say that's that's you know another
interesting book along these lines and
then you know there's many others that
we could discuss but I've said this
before uh about this particular book
that the uh at the Press was kind enough
to send me uh about a year and a half
ago Nick Lanz Fang numina I mean when I
given all the hype around this book I
was a little disappointed when I
actually read it because I was like well
I mean this is just the sort of typical
stuff that we were doing in Continental
philosophy around the you know 1990s and
uh you know going back into the 80s and
the turn of the century
um it's not bad but it's not brilliant
and it's not like the book that we need
to read in order to understand or grasp
our situation for everything any more
than is being a nothingness or you know
um the critique of pure reason or any of
these others and it gets brought up a
lot by people who I think haven't read
very closely this book or the people
that it's referencing right so there's a
lot of uh cool talking about like you
know Thai and deridan to lose and
Heidegger and Kant and you know weird
things where it's like you know kind of
a computer code and all these
interesting Reflections on the
possibilities for AI and you know uh the
planet itself and all that but it's
I mean I think it's
it's not the text to understand
everything with so we got a whole bunch
of things that if if you've got a better
word for these kinds of texts that isn't
demeaning saying oh they're all just you
know gibberish or gobbledygook or you
know uh Charlotte Henry or something
like that because they definitely aren't
every single one of these texts I would
say is worth reading even if they're
texts that you know myself I would say I
I definitely don't agree with these are
all interesting these are all worthwhile
I don't want to put them down but they
definitely don't give you what it is
that it seems a lot of people attribute
to them particularly people who don't
seem to have read them at all or read
them very carefully and so I wouldn't
say avoid them
definitely read them if you have the
time but don't feel like your life is
somehow meaningless or incomplete or
empty or you know less uh well guided if
you haven't read these texts because
none of them are the blueprint for
everything so that's where I'll leave up
I would be very interested to see if
other people have better suggestions for
a way to name this kind of phenomenon
and these kinds of texts and so if you
if you have any suggestions feel free to
leave them in the comments and I'm happy
to entertain them